welcome to data science engineer salary
skills and resume my name is Richard
Kirchner with the simply learn team that
is www.simpleandsensational.com a go
over a little sample resume at the end
keep in mind that a lot of these
different terms and we're focusing on
data science our last video was on
machine learning engineer a lot of these
terms overlap greatly so understanding
both what your focus is and what you
enjoy doing and what's out there in the
job market are important so let's take a
look at the introduction to data science
data science is a systematic way to
analyze a massive amount of data and
extract information from it and you can
see here a couple of examples of pulling
information from the cloud from files on
computers or saved documents
from a sort of databases and we want to
reduce that down to some form of
information we can actually use so we
look at the data science is mainly
needed for better decision making either
A or B do we buy or do we sell our stock
do we market which group are we going to
market to predictive analysis what will
happen next this is probably the most
commonly used we talk about data science
and people are talking about that as
predictive you know is this are we gonna
have a good return next year we're gonna
have a bad return what's going on with
the business are we gonna have a lot of
forest fires this year are we not those
kind of things what are we gonna predict
pattern recognition is there any
important hidden information in the
pattern and this is across the board we
might look at all this different
information crimes tracking down crimes
in
our police force is becoming more and
more common where they look for
commonality and then they're able to go
in there and say okay we need to
investigate what's going on here because
this group of people has the same kind
of input off of Facebook and everything
else as these other five people who
created committed certain crimes and we
look at data science we can answer a lot
of questions as well how many viewers
like the same movies which route will
help me reach faster
that's the Traveling Salesman program
you know how can I hit the most spots in
the shortest amount of time will this AC
work for three years or fell earlier yes
or no is this a good buy or not who will
win the World Cup so who is a data
science engineer are you a data science
engineer or are you gonna be looking for
a different field what exactly is a data
science engineer well a data science
engineer is someone who has programming
experience in Python and our expert
level knowledge ability to write
proficient codes and the we have Python
and our I'm going to say Python or R
once you've become really proficient at
one language transferring those skills
into another one is usually fairly easy
now ours a little different because it
is an analytics platform so going from
Python to R if you already know the data
analytics in Python moving to R is
pretty easy now R doesn't have all the
other code that you can access with
Python there's so many things you can do
with Python that are not data analytics
so that's important to keep in mind that
you should probably be pretty
well-rounded in Python and really have a
solid foundation in R or ever solid
foundation in R and be well rounded in
another programming language where you
really get the programming side of it
strong SQL and big data experience so
you have to have a strong coding skill
with hands on big data experience and of
course we're showing SQL here most
commonly used whether you're using a
Microsoft SQL server or MySQL server you
can also start thinking Hadoop and spark
in big data access Hadoop file system is
not a huge jump
if you've already learned your SQL and
you've already learned your basics in
coding Hadoop sits on top of all that
and there's a wonder
full job creating huge clusters of data
but you really need to know your SQL cuz
that is so common in most of the large
companies now accessing their data and
an ability to visualize models and
troubleshoot code of the models this is
a kind of an interesting one because
these models are can get very
complicated so you get to be able to
break them down into something that you
can put the pieces together and digest
each of the pieces so being able to
visualize these models is very important
and then being able to drill down and
troubleshoot the different models or the
pieces in those models they need to be a
versatile problem solver equipped with
strong analytical and quantitative
skills a self-starter with a strong
sense of personal responsibility and
technical orientation this is an
interesting one because when you talk
about data science engineer it's such a
new field that most companies don't have
it well-defined they don't know what
they're looking for you might not even
know what you're looking for you might
have an idea and you're looking for
patterns but where do those patterns
lead you so you really need that
self-starter side to jump in there and
figure out where to go and be able to
communicate that back to the team and
there we go we have a strong product
intuition data analysis skills and
business presentation skills and this
was talking about is you got to bring
that back to the team so if you don't
have a strong product intuition if you
don't know what's going on with the
company what they need and where you're
going with your analysis it's going to
be a dead end
and you got to be able to present that
to the shareholders to your coworkers
which leads us to great teammate with
excellent interpersonal skills and this
is kind of a strange one because you
spend so much time behind your desk so
you have to be able to kind of float
between your studying all the data and
being able to explain this to people in
simple terms that they can understand
no one wants somebody to come up and say
yeah the Peace Corps on the F score is
this that and the other thing and you
might have two people in the room
understand you you have to be able to
sit down and explain what that means and
why so let's take a look at the data
science skill set we talk about data
science engineer skill set we're talking
about database knowledge statistics
programming tools data wrangling
probably the least favorite and most
used machine learning data visualization
and then the touch on big data and so
we'll start with database knowledge
the most common databases of course your
SQL structured query language think rows
and columns it's an essential language
for extracting a large amount of data
from datasets so knowledge of the SQL is
mandatory for data science engineers and
you can see there's tools required
there's the Oracle database
I mentioned my sequel server Microsoft
sequel server Teradata
there are so many different forms of SQL
and it'll just keep coming back and
coming back so if you don't have a solid
basic understanding of SQL go get it
very important because it will come up
you know it's if you don't know it it's
gonna bite you and statistics of course
we are you know that's what this is all
about is figuring out and predicting
things so you need to know your
statistics statistics is a subset of
mathematics that deals with collecting
analyzing and Terpening data therefore
data scientist needs to know statistics
so you need to understand your
probabilities and what that means and
what the peace core means in the f-score
and means and mode and median all that
information standard deviation all of
those you need to be aware of and then
we get into the programming tools and I
mentioned this earlier a little bit but
you need to master any one of these
specific programming languages
programming tools such as our Python SAS
are essential to perform analytics in
data and again you know you can move in
there and you can be an expert in just R
you can be an expert in just SAS and a
little bit you can be an expert in
Python because most of these when we're
talking about data science and data
wrangling you really kind of get down to
the point where you really need to have
a full programming language at least a
basics and if you're gonna be working in
data science Python right now is the
main one but you know there's also Java
C++ so you need to know a solid language
at least the basics of it so you can
understand how to do basic iterations
and things like that I always found that
interesting that my sister who runs a
university data analytics Center that's
the first question she asked for people
candidates to come and work for us how
do you iterate through data you'd be
amazed at how many people don't
understand that very basic concept in
programming so when we look at our our
is a free software environment for
statistical computing and graphs
supports most machine learning
algorithms for data analytics like
regression
Association clustering and etc Python
Python is an open-source general-purpose
programming language and there's our
general-purpose I was just talking about
you need to know a little bit about
Python libraries like numpy and site pi
are used in data science site pi yeah
numpy in site pi are very central to
Python and I'd throw pandas in there
also that module those are very central
to working with Python and data
analytics and then SAS SAS can mine
alter manage and retrieve data from a
variety of sources it can perform
statistical analysis on the data so
where r is the open source platform SAS
is more like the paid-for platform and
so it has some things more automated
because people are paying for it
developing it but it's also if you
really start using it as a company
you're gonna have to pay for it where r
is free store is free software pythons
also open source and free to use so
we're gonna talk a little bit about data
wrangling and I mentioned earlier that
is both the probably people's least
favorite aspects of data science and
also probably one of the places you
spend the most time so when we talk
about data wrangling it is a process of
transforming raw data into an
appropriate format to make it useful for
analytics and it involves cleaning raw
data structuring raw data and enriching
raw data and this gets interesting
because you'll get stuck on something
like in Python you might get stuck on
something that is a date time based on
an integer 64 numpy set you might not
know what all those terms mean because
you work in R or something like that but
you get the point that it's all one
particular format and then you have to
figure out how to switch it so that the
computer can see it correctly in
whatever format you're using or whatever
analytics platform you're using
knowledge of machine learning techniques
such as supervised machine learning
decision trees linear regression KNN etc
is useful for few job roles so this is
kind of interesting because sometimes
that's the center of the job role of a
data scientist and sometimes you just
have to be able to apply the programming
skills to it so you can get the answer
and let somebody else fine-tune your
machine learning techniques so really
depends on what it is you're working
with and you can see here we have our
nearest neighbor set up where it groups
things together that look
like linear regression you're drawing a
line through the data or curve so you
can predict what the next value is gonna
be and then our nice decision tree we
start splitting things up and says you
know it's sunny out yes let's go
swimming
no it's raining we're not gonna go
swimming yes it's sunny out we might go
swim it's raining
we'll stay indoors yes we'll walk the
dog no so you have a decision tree that
helps figure out how you get to the end
result so decision trees can be pretty
powerful and data visualization data
visualization is the study and creation
of visual representation of data data
visualization uses algorithms
statistical graphs plots information
graphics and other tools to communicate
information clearly and effectively this
one you really have to master as a data
science this one you really have to
master as a data scientist and there
certainly are so many different tools to
use to visualize it but when you're
communicating a picture's worth a
thousand words
when you can put a picture up and people
can look at and go oh I see what's going
on that's worth a lot more than saying
yeah this is good people hear that and
they just kind of go okay it's good but
why and you might say okay these numbers
make it look good no people want
something they can see and there
certainly is tableau is probably one of
the most popular ones out there Caleb
you power bi Google Data studio in
Python there's the PI kit and Seabourn
there's all kinds of different options
for visualization you need to master
probably at least one or two of them so
you understand how they work and how
they're different
and then big data big data is a massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
and processed using traditional methods
big data has various benefits like
access to social data can enable
organizations to tune their business
strategies big data can improve customer
experience and so we're usually when you
say big data we're almost always talking
about Hadoop and Apache spark it used to
be Hadoop as your file system so that's
how you store all your data going across
the nodes and there certainly are other
ways to store it when we talk about
Hadoop we're usually talking about at
least 10 terabytes of data when you do
with a Hadoop file structure and then
you can use spark where Hadoop process
is on and off the hard drive so it's
continually reading and writing to the
hard drive spark is running in your RAM
and so when you're doing a very
intensive data process you'll run a
spark setup which will spread those
processes over multiple computers and of
course know the to combine and spark
sits on top of Hadoop and you get your
big data
there's also talent tableau has its own
server setup there's Splunk Cassandra
you'll hear the Cassandra database Penta
hoe I'm not even sure how to pronounce
that one has not one I've worked with
certainly there's a lot of options for
Big Data the two big players are coarse
Hadoop and spark and even your sequel
servers and my sequel servers will
spread across five different servers and
you can be talking about Big Data across
five servers with those pulling them in
to say Apache spark to do your high end
processing and then there's
non-technical skills probably the most
important one in data science and any of
our data analytics is intellectual
curiosity updating knowledge by reading
contents and relevant books on trends in
data science this is such there's so
much going on in this field and it's
exploding now that it's hard to keep
track of it all so you really need to
have that curiosity in the data science
probably even more so than a lot of
other fields but I would say in just
today's world you need intellectual
curiosity because things are changing so
rapidly in today's world the way that's
going with our technology understanding
how the problem solved can impact the
business business acumen this is the one
where a lot of people kind of skip over
you have to have a little business sense
if you don't know how it's gonna impact
the business you're gonna be in trouble
why do they want to even pay you to be
there unless they know what's going on
and they're getting something in return
so this is your bottom line for your
paycheck is what's going on with the
business house is gonna impact the
business what are you doing for them in
communication skills companies look for
someone who can clearly in fluently
translate technical findings to a
non-technical team and I've talked about
this a bunch and I can't even iterate
this enough if you are struggling with
your communication skills work on
building them you know
have to be you know this isn't rocket
science where you have to know all these
complicated terms what you need to do is
take the complicated terms you know from
data science and reduce that down to
something that anybody can understand so
when you come up and you have you know
KN n no one knows a KN n is you know
unless they're in data science nearest
neighbor looking for things that match
together you gotta explain that to
people who do not have the technical
skill in the data science arena and a
data science engineer needs to work with
everyone in the organization including
customers so it's teamwork and that's
always one that throws people for a loop
but ultimately you are analyzing your
customers information and so sometimes
getting in there and rolling up your
sleeves if you're let's say you're doing
data analysis for a sales team and
you're backing a sales team you might
have to get in there and go start making
some sells and making some phone calls
and see what it's like what does that
team doing when they call 15 people and
cold calls and then they do a follow-up
two weeks later or three weeks later
which one works better two or three does
it work better to call and send a fax
call and send an email you know when you
should you show up in person if it's
that kind of business so working with
everybody including the customer is very
important with the data and with this
kind of setup and non-technical skills
for a data scientist so let's take a
look at some of the roles a data science
plays in the job market let's drill in
there just a little bit here so when you
have a data scientist they're gonna
perform predictive analysis and identify
trend and patterns that can help in
better decision making companies hiring
data scientist include Apple Adobe
Google Microsoft I would say that's even
expanding down to smaller companies you
know where you're talking about only a
hundred employees or something like that
they're starting to look at data
scientists because they need them to
come in and be a part of that team and
the rule is understanding challenges of
a system and offer best solutions this
should always be the goal of a data
scientist is to be looking at the whole
system and then trying to find those
patterns that are gonna best enhance the
company or the business or the whatever
group may be working with the sales team
or the marketing team and you can see
languages pretty important to have a
these are a number of different
again it depends on your own specialty
there's all kinds of different
variations but we have our SAS Python
MATLAB SQL hi Pig spark you should have
at least a knowledge of all of these
maybe a Python programmer never used our
download it go through the basics so at
least you know what's going on an R
versus Python because R is pretty
powerful for doing a very quick display
and then of course a lot of things you
can do in Python you have to be able to
do queries on database from time to time
create and modify algorithms which can
be used to reduce information from large
databases and usually this is one of
those things you do at the beginning you
set it up and then you kind of let it go
until it breaks and then you have to go
back and fix it because your query isn't
working that certainly is a very common
thing to have happen especially if
you're pulling data off the web and the
internet and then we have some more
companies that are hiring data analysis
like IBM DHL HP and so we're talking
about data analysis the role is
responsible for a variety of tasks just
as visualization optimization and
processing large amount of data and so
when you're talking about a data analyst
we're also we're still talkin a lot of
the same stuff but you'll see we now
thrown in JavaScript and HTML in here
because that's pretty common with a data
analyst versus a data scientist and you
can see that SQL is still pretty solid
and also C C++ is pretty big so some
companies also use Java so output job in
the languages also on that for a data
analyst and then you have a data
architect ensuring that data engineers
have best tools and systems to work with
and so companies hiring a data architect
are like visa Logitech coca-cola
they create blueprints for data
management with the best security
measures
I cannot highlight that a data
architecture really spends a lot of time
with security measures that's big how
many hacks have we seen in the last year
a large companies have lost data for
millions of their customers and how
badly that affects them and we're
looking at languages sqc that SQL is
pretty solid across all of these under a
data architect XML that's one that a lot
of the data science jobs don't really
you don't see as much but you're going
to see more XML with a data architect
because there's a lot of XML files that
are
your security measure is embedded in
them and of course your hive Pig those
are Hadoop systems for doing some basic
queries so instead of doing the high-end
queries you know how these simplified
query systems built into Hadoop and
spark so if you're using big data you're
gonna want to know your spark also and
then we have our data engineer the data
engineer updates the existing systems
with better version of the current
technologies to improve the efficiency
of the databases think admin here a lot
of work tracking down what version
you're in of the different programs what
version of python are you using what
version of are are using what version of
C++ so companies hiring data engineers
or like Amazon Spotify Facebook and they
develop construct test and maintain
architectures such as databases and long
scale processing systems here we have
our languages or SQL our MATLAB SAS SPSS
Python Java Ruby C++ Perl hive Pig
you pretty much as a data engineer at
this level when you talk about admin and
updating all these data bases need to
know all the different stuff that's
being used in the company and you're
testing out these structures to make
sure they work and so you really are
talking admin level kind of setup so if
you like spinning up an admin on to a
Google cloud service or Amazon Cloud
service now you start to get an idea
what we're talking about because then
you can test it out up there and then
you can bring it back and update it to
the company statistician creates new
methodologies for engineers to apply and
so when you look at this this is where
we're digging into the math of which
models to use what setups gonna work
what kind of activation do we have on
our neural network these little tweaks
are gonna make a big difference and we
look for methodologies at a large level
what kind of data are we gonna be
looking at how we're gonna pull it
together companies hiring a data
engineer or we're talking about
statistic Oh Johnson and Johnson and of
course these companies probably hire a
little bit of everything but they have a
lot of statistic at the roll extract an
offer valuable reports from the data
clusters through statistical theories
and data organization and the languages
across the board we're still seeing SQL
our MATLAB SAS SPSS data that's a new
one
seen in some of the other roles Python
Perl an older version and there
shouldn't be a surprise because a lot of
these companies probably built a lot of
the original packages on Perl if you
look at Johnson & Johnson and of course
your big data high pig and spark and
then our database administrator I
mentioned the other one is an admin
they're more an admin level for the
software itself so administrator is
another level some of the tasks involved
are monitoring operating and maintaining
databases installation configuration
defining schemas training users etc and
this is interesting training users
because when you build a database and
you define all the different tables that
are embedded in that database and how
they're all connected the end users got
to have that information otherwise
you're in trouble when we have companies
hiring data engineers of course tableau
Twitter reddit the role ensures that all
the databases are available to all
relevant users and getting a little
security in there what role do they have
is allowed in and not and as performing
quickly and as being kept safe and you
better be ready to spend some time in
security because again that's a very big
thing nowadays with the number of people
who hacked into these databases and the
languages are gonna be covered you have
your c-sharp your java SQL Ruby on Rails
XML again there's that XML because a lot
of your security is embedded in XML
files Python all the main players
depending on what the company's using
data and analytics manager so when you
manager that means if somebody's gonna
sit on top and organize the people
underneath so they're gonna improve the
business process as an intermediary
between business and IT oh you better
have some really good communication
skills for this one some of the
companies hiring a data engineers are
Coursera Motorola
slack and of course these companies are
hiring data scientists and almost all of
these fields so the role oversees the
data science operations and assigns the
duties to the team according to skills
and expertise so that's a big one you
better be able to communicate what's
going on help your team members come out
and be able to communicate with other
people so sometimes your job is just
being able to get people to talk to each
other the big thing on that is is the
whole communication line going from one
end to the
there because you can't communicate all
the information that everybody's working
on you have to pretty much come in there
and help people communicate what there's
going on and also know what they're up
to without being micromanagement because
that will crash a company if you
micromanage everybody but if you just
let them do whatever they want and they
never talk to each other that will also
destroy the company you gotta find that
nice middle ground and you really have
to have an overview of everything as a
data and analytics manager one of the
things I mean you know it's good to have
at least one or two solid basis of
programming under your belt for a data
analytics manager but you do need to
have a very general understanding of all
the different tools being used so that
you know what's going on with your
different team members of course SQL our
SAS Java Python MATLAB all of those are
big business analytics so this is when
you're talking about your bi or business
intelligence and your business analytics
very important to know this kind of a
subdivision of a lot of the other stuff
we've talked about a lot of the other
roles we've looked at so you possess
specialized knowledge of their business
domain and apply that knowledge and
analysis specifically to the operation
of the business so you may be a
specialist in banking you might be a
genetics engineer so you know about
genetics you might just be general
business helping them marketing so a lot
of companies hiring data engineer or
Oracle uber Dell and the role act as a
link between the data engineers and the
management executives so it's very
similar to when go back up here we look
at data analytics manager a business
analytics is gonna also kind of fill
that role in between but they're more
specialized in business and you better
know SQL because we're talking about
business specifically most of the large
companies are storing their data that's
up and running right now that people are
accessing to purchase something on the
home depot website or the uber they're
logging in you better know your SQL it's
very central to business analytics so
let's go ahead and take a look at the
data science engineer salary trends and
you'll see that our sources Glassdoor as
we're pulling a lot of our data from
average base pay is around 117 thousand
in the US the average salary and when we
look at India we're talking about 950
thousand
year and those are based on some of them
you need to go ahead and dig deeper to
find out what education level versus
entry level but those are pretty solid
base once you're in the industry and
once you created your career in there
and we look at the job titles the most
common job title is data scientist
business intelligence manager is the
second greatest one that's kind of good
to note that's why they put that up
there as being its own little
subcategory of data science managers a
business intelligence managers it's such
a high level of jobs and then we looked
at some of the other ones data architect
business intelligence architect again
your bi your business intelligence gets
its own ranking because it's such a high
level you know it's a business people
want their businesses to make money so
that's who's hiring of course data
engineer business intelligence developer
business intelligence consultant
business intelligence analyst business
analysts and data analysts so you can
look at the data analysts as being the
general one that doesn't go specific to
business so if you're looking just for
your career as far as getting a job
probably should have some kind of
business understanding in the background
and again you know your companies want
to make money so they're gonna hire
someone who knows business banking
business if you're specialized in
banking or retail if you specialize in
retail and marketing and you can see
here on the data science salary trends
and the growth and data science job
listings it's continually going up its
since 2014 to 2012 we've gone from 400
to 600 that's a pretty big increase so
you know a huge growth in this market so
one of the biggest growing markets right
now for jobs in careers so let's go
ahead and take a look at building a
resume always exciting putting ourselves
out selling ourselves and if you looked
at some of our other videos dealing with
some resumes you'll see a trend here the
top part is so different than what
resumes were in the 90s in the 2000 to
2010 they've evolved they've really
evolved it used to be 2000 2010 maybe
LinkedIn maybe one other reference now
you're gonna see that we want those
references
this is a sales tactic which now has
come in two resumes used to be that if
you're a real estate agent every real
estate agent I knew I used to deal with
real estate software for the real estate
industry back in the 90s every real
estate agent one their picture on their
business card they wanted them their
picture if they could put on their
contracts they wanted people to see the
face so that's really a big change is to
make sure that it stands out you stand
out here's a picture of somebody so
you're more than just a couple letters
and a name but of course you need your
contact information should always be at
the top you have your summary what are
you focusing on be a little careful with
your summary because if you have
everything in your summary and then they
scroll down to experience and education
and skills they're gonna stop the second
you repeat yourself in your resume that
usually means to the reader hey this
person doesn't have anything more to
offer me I'm done so be a little careful
how you word your summary most companies
appreciate when you come in here and
you've adjusted this summary to be both
about you and how you're gonna serve
that company so it's worth researching
that company to find out how those
connect and put that in the summary take
some time to do that that's it's
actually a pretty big deal and the
references are huge also especially in
data science when you're talking about
any of the programming or data science
data analytics having a place to go
where they can look it up and scroll
down and see different things you're
doing whether it's LinkedIn in this case
which is the business profile most
commonly used github we have stuff
published Facebook I'm always hesitant
because that tends to push more towards
social media type jobs and other jobs
but certainly there's people who have
facebook who do marketing and stuff like
that but these links having these basic
links here is important people are
starting to look for that for some other
set up maybe you have a personal website
this is a good place to put that so that
they now have a multitude of links that
go back to you and highlight who you are
and then the next part or next four
parts so for the next four parts we have
a combination of experience education
skills certifications and you can see
they're organized if you have you know a
lot of people like to see what kind of
degree
you have they want to know where it came
from and if you just got out of college
you're gonna put education at the top
and then maybe you'll put skills after
that and then your experience at the
bottom if you've been in the field for
years you know my degree just to give
you my age goes back to the 1990s so I
usually put an education at the very
bottom and then because a lot of the
stuff I'm trying to sell myself on right
now is my skills I actually put that at
the top and I'll put my education my
certifications at the bottom my skills
and then my experience is since it's a
huge part of my resume goes next you can
organize these in whatever order you
want that's gonna work best for you and
sell you so remember you're selling
yourself this is your image probably
don't wear an old tie-dye t-shirt with
holes in it you know something nice
because it is professional and of course
your summary your and then what do you
have to offer the company and again when
I put out resumes and I haven't done a
resume in a while you go in there and
you can take this and reorganize this so
if the company is looking for something
specific you might put the experiences
specific to that company you might even
take experience if you have like a long
job history like I do I've gone into a
lot of different things you might leave
out those companies or those experiences
that had nothing to do with data science
because it just becomes overwhelming
resume should only take about 30 seconds
to glance over maybe a minute tops
because after that point you've lost the
person's interest and if they want to
dig deeper they now have links they have
your website they have LinkedIn and they
can now take this and they come back to
it they go okay let's look at this
person a little closer so a quick
overview this is your cell sheet selling
you to the company so always tie it to
the company so that you have that what
am I gonna give this company what are
they gonna get from me we've covered a
lot on data science engineer in general
and we've gone over a basic resume
remember keep it simple short and direct
that is so important with that resume
thank you for joining us with data
science engineer salary skills and
resume again my name is Richard Kirchner
with the simply learned team that's wwm
play learn comm come visit our website
to learn more about what we have to
offer in the education and getting you
certified if you have
questions you can also post them down
below in the YouTube video we do have
people monitoring this channel hi there
if you like this video subscribe to the
simple learn YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified click here